On the 7th of October 1849, a heavily
intoxicated man was found lying in the gutter
outside a pub in Baltimore. As is traditional with
intoxicated men in gutters, this one cut a fairly
unimpressive figure. He was dressed in someone
else's clothes, his hair had been carefully
styled to look exactly like toilet brush,
and he was muttering to himself incoherently.
In other words, he could have been any
drunk in any gutter almost anywhere in
the world. But this man wasn't just
anyone. He was Edgar Allan Poe,
one of the greatest writers who ever lived.
And exactly how he ended up in that gutter
in 1849 remains one of the biggest
mysteries in the history of literature.
Now, I know what you're thinking - isn't it
pretty bloody obvious how an extremely drunk
man ended up in a gutter outside a pub. But, bear
with me. Because this plot is about to thicken.
Poe was taken to the nearby Washington Medical
College for treatment, and it was there that
something odd happened - or should I say,
*didn't* happen. Considering the state he was in,
everyone assumed Poe was raging drunk. But even
the drunkest of men will sober up sooner or later,
whereas Poe remained in the same delirious,
incoherent state for four days straight...
...and then he died.
By all accounts it was a strange way
to go, especially since he was only 40
at the time. But things were about to
get stranger still. Because it turned
out that Poe had been missing for almost
a week before he was found in that gutter,
and to this day we have no idea where he went
or what he did in the meantime - he seems to
have just... disappeared off the face of the earth
only to turn up half mad and die a few days later.
It's hard to miss the irony that Poe's mysterious
death reads like something straight out of one
of his own stories, and there are some genuinely
wild theories about exactly what happened to him.
But before we get onto Poe's death,
we should probably talk about his
life. Because what a life it was.
Most people think of Edgar Allan Poe
predominantly as a horror writer,
but the truth is he was so much more than that.
He single-handedly invented detective fiction,
was one of the founders of sci-fi alongside
authors like Mary Shelley and Jules Verne,
and he was one of the first people to
explore the art of the short story.
It’s also been largely forgotten that
before he took storytelling seriously Poe
had an extremely promising career
in the military, and he might have
gone right to the top if he hadn't got
himself court-martialled... on purpose.
He was also something of a polymath,
and despite never having any formal
scientific training he used the power
of his frankly frightening imagination
to somehow predict the origin of
the universe and the existence of
black holes several decades before the
actual scientists came up with them.
And then there’s what is probably my favourite
story about Edgar Allan Poe - one that,
fittingly enough, comes from beyond
the grave. I don’t want to spoil it,
but let’s just say it involves an accidental
prediction so utterly spectacular some people
believe Poe might just have been a time
traveller. Stick around till the end of
the video and I'll fill you in on the
details. Trust me - it'll be worth it.
For now, without further ado, this
is the remarkable, incredible,
near-unbelievable life story… of Edgar Allan Poe.
Edgar *Poe* was born on the
19th of January 1849 in Boston,
Massachusetts. Early life for little
Edgar was... well, it wasn't great.
His father left the family home and never
came back when Edgar was just a year old,
and a year after that his mother Eliza died of
what is today assumed to have been tuberculosis.
Just in case that wasn't a bad enough start
to life for Edgar and his two siblings,
they were then split up and sent
to live with 3 different families.
Presumably thoroughly traumatised by
this point, Edgar ended up in Richmond
Virginia with Scottish Merchant
John Allan and his wife Frances.
He was never formally adopted, but
the Allans did have Edgar baptised,
and that's where he acquired the missing
third of that catchy name of his.
The Allans were one of the wealthiest families in
all of Richmond, and Edgar was given an education
befitting his new station, including a 5
year stint in the UK where he studied at
some of the finest boarding schools around. In
1826 he attended the University of Virginia,
founded 7 years earlier by some
bloke called Thomas Jefferson,
where he studied ancient and modern languages.
Poe had always been an excellent student, but like
many young men attending university for the first
time, rather than concentrate on his studies he
decided to go absolutely bloody mental instead.
Within a year he was forced to drop out after
amassing substantial drinking and gambling debts.
That was pretty bad, but things were about to get
even worse. Because, like many filthy rich men,
John Allan absolutely detested the idea of
wasting money. In order to make sure his foster
son couldn’t fritter away any more of it losing
at cards, Allan simply turned off the money tap.
Which is why, at the age of 18, a flat broke Edgar
Allan Poe decided to join the army. Taking the
stereotype of writers being frail, bookish-types
and bayonetting it into a billion bloody bits,
Poe took to the army like a duck to
hoisin sauce. He made short work of
the lowest rungs on the military ladder, and was
eventually selected from among 500 of his peers
for promotion to sergeant major, the highest
rank possible for a noncommissioned officer.
In 1829 he left the army to enrol as a
cadet at the United States Military Academy,
better known as West Point. But he lasted
less than a year after realising his true
calling was not with war, but words.
Rather than just, you know, quit,
he decided to go out with a bit of a bang by
deliberately getting himself court-martialled.
Exactly how he did it is
the subject of some debate,
but according to legend he was dismissed after
turning up butt naked to a parade ground drill.
Sadly that story’s probably apocryphal -
most historians agree he simply ignored
his duties until those in charge were left
with no option but to give Poe the heave-ho.
With his military career behind him
he made the bold decision to dedicate
himself to writing full time. That might
not sound like such a big deal these days,
but back then it was practically unheard of.
Poe is widely accepted as having been the
first American writer to make a living
solely from writing - in other words,
he quit a promising career in the military
to do a job that didn't even exist yet.
Perhaps unsurprisingly, it… didn't go all that
well. It wasn't that he found it difficult to
find buyers for his stories - he didn’t. The
trouble was they paid like shit. Copyright law
was still in its infancy, meaning rather than
pay local writers a fair price for their work,
American magazines could simply print
stories by British authors for free.
There was precious little point paying
Poe a pretty penny when you could lift
literature straight from the limeys.
Trying saying that ten times fast.
With stories and poems not yet putting
food on the table - let alone paying the
rent - in 1835 Poe got himself a job
as a staff writer and critic at the
*Southern Literary Messenger* in Richmond.
The chance to earn a steady - albeit fairly
pitiful - wage was a major breakthrough in
Poe’s career... or at least it would have
been if he hadn't got himself fired inside of
the first month for being drunk on the job.
Not that he let unemployment get him down - he put
his new-found spare time to good use by finding
love. And when I say ‘love’ I mean he... married
his cousin. His... 13-year-old cousin. Yeeeeeah.
The happy cousins--I mean couple -
were wed by a minister named Amasa
Converse. That random fact has no
bearing whatsoever on this story,
but I had to include it because history
should never have forgotten that neckbeard.
A month after getting the boot from
the *Messenger* Poe was rehired,
and this time things went much more
smoothly. Not only was he able to get
many of his own stories and poems
published, he also started to make
a name for himself as a literary critic.
An.. *absolutely savage* literary critic.
Over the next few years he bounced
around several different publications,
writing stories and poems and just generally
eviscerating the work of his colleagues for fun.
In 1841 he casually invented an entirely new
genre of fiction when he published a short
story called *The Murders in the Rue Morgue.*
It was both the first modern detective story
and the first locked room mystery, and it
featured a character called C. Auguste Dupin,
an eccentric but brilliant amateur
detective who uses his almost supernatural
analytical abilities to solve crimes.
If that's sounding just a tad familiar,
it's probably because a certain rather
famous fictional detective was very clearly
inspired by Poe's creation - without Dupin,
there would have been no Sherlock Holmes.
By the way, it's thought that Poe came up
with the idea for Dupin while doing a bit
of detective work himself in figuring out the
trick behind the chess-playing automaton known
as the mechanical turk. I covered the Turk
back in 2020 and it's one of my favourite
videos on the channel - I highly recommend
you check it out if you haven't already.
In 1843 Poe entered a story called The Gold-Bug
into a national competition. It won the grand
prize, pocketing him a cool hundred dollars
- probably the most he was ever paid for a
single piece of work. But its impact was far more
than just financial. In fact, you could say the
Gold-Bug was indirectly responsible for saving
tens, perhaps hundreds of thousands of lives.
A key element of the story’s plot involved
a real cryptogram that, once solved,
revealed the location of some good old
fashioned buried treasure. Cryptography
wasn’t well known in those days, and in the
decades after its publication the Gold-Bug
would introduce tens of thousands of young
readers to the concept for the first time.
Among them were Leo Marks and William Friedman,
both of whom read Poe’s stories as children and
found the idea of cryptography so fascinating that
in later life they went on to work in the field.
Leo Marks became chief cryptographer
for the Special Operations Executive,
a secret organisation credited by General
Eisenhower with shortening the Second World
War by at least 3 months, and William
Friedman, along with his wife Elizebeth,
went on to become one of the most influential
codebreakers in history. As the chief
cryptanalyst at the Signal Intelligence
Service during the Second World War,
his teams broke multiple Japanese ciphers,
saving countless lives in the process.
In 1845, Poe's now legendary poem the Raven
was published in the New York Evening Mirror
and was an instant hit. It's often reported
that Poe died penniless and in obscurity,
but only half of that is actually true -
like most of his work he didn't make much
money from the Raven, selling it for just $9.
But it immediately struck a chord with readers
all over America and beyond, transforming
Poe into a household name almost overnight.
To this day, the Raven remains one of the
most famous and best-loved poems of all time,
as well as one of the most quoted -
and parodied - pieces of literature
in history. Even now, references to the
iconic poem pop up all over the place,
from the Simpsons, to the NHL, and
from League of Legends to Star Trek.
Three years after the Raven Poe published an
essay called Eureka. It was a major departure
from his typical style, covering, of all
things, his ideas about the makeup of the
universe itself. You might think that’s
a fairly unusual area of interest for
a writer with zero scientific training, and
plenty of people at the time agreed. In fact,
Eureka was so downright odd that some viewed it
as compelling evidence Poe was losing his marbles.
Little did they know that,
many decades after Poe’s death,
Eureka would prove to be one of the
most unexpectedly insightful essays
ever written. That might sound like a pretty
big statement, but, well.. see for yourself.
In the mid 19th century when Eureka was written,
the overwhelming scientific consensus was that the
universe was infinite, unchanging, and eternal.
But Eureka describes a dynamic, ever-shifting
universe born from a single primordial particle
that expanded outwards to create all matter. In
other words, Edgar Allen Poe predicted the Big
Bang almost 80 years before scientists did.
Hidden within the complex labyrinth that is
Eureka are also allusions to the relationship
between energy and matter, the role
of the speed of light in the universe,
the existence of black holes, and the concept of a
cyclical universe that’s born and reborn over and
over again - it would be decades until any of
these ideas appeared in scientific literature.
Eureka is so remarkable that even today
scholars aren't really sure what to do
with it. Alongside all the brilliant bits
Poe also got plenty wrong. But what he got
right is uncanny. Normal people just shouldn't
be able to randomly guess the deepest darkest
secrets of the universe just by having a
bit of a think while sitting on the toilet.
Eureka turned out to be one of Poe's last
major works. On the 27th of September 1849
at the age of just 40, he got on a train
in Richmond to go to New York where he
was living at the time. For the following
week nobody has any idea whatsoever what
happened to him until he turned up in that
Baltimore gutter days before his death.
One theory is that he may have been subjected to
something called 'cooping,' a kind of political
fraud in which victims were kidnapped and forced
to vote for certain candidates in elections,
often multiple times while
wearing a variety of disguises.
That might sound, well, mental. But cooping was
actually quite common in Baltimore at the time,
and it would at least explain some
of the stranger details of the case,
like why Poe was in Baltimore in the first place
and why he was wearing someone else's clothes.
Many victims of cooping were beaten or plied
with alcohol or drugs, a combination of which
might also explain Poe’s apparent delirium when
he was found, and perhaps even his cause of death.
Cooping is certainly one of the most
popular theories about Poe’s death
and disappearance, but it isn’t the only one.
Poe was buried in an unmarked
grave in a Baltimore graveyard,
but as the years went by and his popularity
as a writer continued to grow, it was decided
that he needed a more fitting resting place. In
1875 a fancy monument was erected nearby, and
Poe’s remains were exhumed so that they could be
reburied at the new site. When his body was moved,
the local gravedigger claimed he could clearly
hear Poe’s brain rattling around inside his skull.
At the time nobody thought anything much about it,
but these days we know the gravedigger’s
story makes no sense - there’s simply no
way a human brain could have survived 26
years underground without decomposing. But
if it wasn’t Poe’s grey matter bumping
around inside his head… what was it?
Well, it’s possible that little lump may
have been the calcified remains of a brain
tumour. If that’s true it might explain
Poe’s odd behaviour and delirium in the
days before his demise, and it would
also give us a clear cause of death.
There have been literally dozens
of other theories over the years,
including everything from mercury poisoning to
rabies or even murder. But the truth is we’ll
likely never know for sure what exactly
killed Edgar Allan Poe. And perhaps it’s
fitting that the death of the great mystery
writer will itself forever remain a mystery.
And speaking of mysteries, it’s time I told
you about the greatest coincidence in history.
In his all-too-short life, Poe wrote precisely
one novel - The Narrative of Arthur Gordon Pym of
Nantucket. The book tells the story of a stowaway
on board a whaling ship called the Grampus.
At some point the Grampus is badly damaged in
a severe storm that only 4 of the crew survive,
and over the course of the following few weeks
adrift at sea, they slowly begin to succumb to
starvation. The crew manage to bring a few
provisions up from the flooded depths of the
ship - including a small tortoise - but it
isn’t enough. And with no land in sight and
nothing else to eat, they eventually turn to
cannibalism. They draw straws, and the loser
is the youngest survivor, a boy called Richard
Parker, who is killed and eaten by the others.
The novel was published in 1838 and
it was largely a flop, but almost 50
years later something incredibly weird happened.
In 1884, a yacht called the Mignonette sank
somewhere in the middle of the Atlantic Ocean.
Just like in Poe’s novel, four men survived
the sinking, and (just like the novel) soon
enough they were starving. As luck would have
it, they managed to catch a turtle, but the
fresh meat didn’t sustain them for long (OK so
it isn’t quite a tortoise but close enough).
Eventually the survivors grew so
desperate they decided one of them
should be sacrificed for the good of
the others. And - just like in Poe’s
novel - it was the youngest member of the
crew who was chosen, and ultimately eaten.
Pretty remarkable right?
But I know what you're thinking -
it’s a pretty weird coincidence,
but… biggest in history? There must have been
dozens of cases of cannibalism aboard ships in
years since Poe died - it’s hardly a miracle that
one of them involved the same number of crew,
a tortoise-slash-turtle, and the
youngest member being sacrificed.
But… there's one piece of information
I haven't told you yet. Something that
transforms this from a quirky coincidence
into something more than a little bit spooky.
I didn’t tell you the name of the
crew member who was eaten - just
like in Poe’s story, his name was Richard Parker.
What. The actual. F*ck.
By the way, if that name is ringing any
bells it might be because the tiger in the
Life of Pi is also called Richard Parker
- author Yann Martel chose it as a kind
of easter egg to pay homage to the greatest
coincidence in literary history. (And, if you
happen to have read the book or seen the film,
you’ll know exactly how fitting the name is.)
Edgar Allen Poe struggled for most of his life to
realise his dream of becoming an author. It’s an
enormous shame that he never got to find out quite
how spectacularly that dream would eventually come
true. Today he is universally regarded as
one of the greatest authors who ever lived,
and his influence on modern fiction has
been so great that without him many of
the stories we know and love would never
even have existed. What a tragedy it is
that he died so young, to fill our
world with his stories… nevermore.
Thanks for watching.